Der Stefan und der Florentin, die haben eine Show. Und wenn sie so beim Reden sind, kommen sie meistens ganz schön in den Flow. Also habt viel Spaß und geniessen die Zeit mit dieser Podcast-Kostbarkeit.
So, schönen guten Tag, mein Name Stefan Thiel, es ist Flo und Tim Will, wir sind beide ein bisschen angepisst, nicht wegen dieses tollen Intros, was wirklich einfach nur super ist. Das war ein schönes, herzergleichendes, liebliches Intro. Nein, weil wir machen immer Tests, ob die Mikros funktionieren, und Floritin macht das immer sehr wichtig. Wenn man nicht richtig klopft, dann ist er direkt sauer aufs Mikro usw. Und jetzt hat er es getestet, es hat offensichtlich nicht funktioniert. Wir haben jetzt eine halbe Stunde aufgenommen. Na gut, wir haben ja ungefähr 30 Sekunden aufgenommen. Wir haben 30 Sekunden aufgenommen. Stefan hat viele Gags über die Musikrichtung Scar gemacht. Das alles wird jetzt im Gipfschrank verschwinden. Diese Gags werden nie das Licht der Öffentlichkeit erfahren. Vielleicht besser so. Aber ich werde es ja nicht wiederholen. Ich war aber im Urlaub und habe mich davor natürlich in, sag ich mal, ein osteuropäisches Land, das nicht näher genannt werden möchte, und dann habe ich mich informiert natürlich im Vorhinein, was in diesem Land so geht, was man da so machen kann, und das allererste, was bei Google stand, wenn man dieses Land eingab, war, die beliebteste Musikrichtung ist Ska. Und ich dachte mir, auf gar keinen Fall. Das wird hart. Das wird hart. Hast du denn Ska-Witz bis jetzt aufgehoben, bis wir richtig aufnehmen? Nee, das war spontan, weil du über Ska geredet hast. Ich habe tatsächlich, ich wohne ja relativ in der Nähe von einem Unterhaltungsetablissement und das heißt, ich höre nachts immer Musik aus der Strasse einfach so.
Und irgendwie in dieser einen Kneipe gibt es einmal in der Woche irgendwie so lateinamerikanische Nacht oder irgendwie sowas. Und die Musik ist ja so, du hörst nur den Bass, der Rest ist alles weg und du hast dieses dum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum und das stundenlang. Es fehlt wie ein langer Song. Ey, Musik an sich ist schon nervig zu hören, wenn man schlafen will. Aber dann dieser konstante stundenlang. Es hat vor allem, es soll irgendwie Elan und Leidenschaftlichkeiten, Bewegungsfreude ausdrücken. Ich liege still im Bett und möchte gerne einschlafen. Und mein Körper sagt, tanz. Und dein Herz auch schon so. Ja. Ja, weil du nicht kannst. Weil du musst, haben wir ja bei deinem DNA-Taste rausgefunden, du bist dann doch zu zehn Prozent Lateinamerikanerin. Und da kommt das natürlich auch dann durch. Da kommt dann, du kannst dich mit auch nicht still, bei den Schultern zucken immer so. Es ist furchtbar und ich weiß genau, dass wenn ich irgendwann mal nach Lateinamerika muss oder so, ich werde nicht schlafen können, weil überall ich diesen einen Rhythmus, es ist schrecklich. Ja, es ist ein bisschen boring, aber Partys sind auch, muss man sagen, wenn man schlafen will, scheiße, oder auch generell objektiv betrachtet, weil dann hörst du auch immer dieses spitze Lachen von Damen manchmal zwischendurch, weil es einfach... Stuhlgerücken, immer Leute stehen auf, um sich Flip zu holen. Und man denkt sich, wo wollen die denn die ganze Zeit hin? Bernd, du warst gerade so im Klo, das habe ich gerade schon gehört. Und dann aber hört man immer dieses Lachen zwischendurch, wo man sagt, so viel kann gar nicht Lustiges gesprochen werden. Wenn ich auf Partys bin, lachen die Leute nie so viel. Nee, wenn wir auf der Bühne stehen, lachen Leute auch nicht so viel, wie in München jetzt zum Beispiel. Da hört man dann sehr viel Stuhlgerücken, also viel Aufstehen, Hinsetzen, viele Flaschen drunter fallen und so. Oh, du sitzt auf meinem Platz, das ja. Immer das Gleiche. Aber ist das gerade so ein Trend, diese latein auf die drei und dann hast du den. Ich such den seit Monaten, ich finde in meinem Kopf das Wort dafür nicht.
Ja, du baust da nur so ein Casio-Keyboard und dann gehst du auf die drei und dann hast du den.
Ne, Bossa Nova meinst du. Also heißt der glaube ich nicht. Der hat einen speziellen... Bossa Nova ist doch sowas in Richtung, ne?
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Dann gibt es doch den...
Ja, oder
geben es auch.
Die gibt es alle.
Wir haben die ganzen Beats,
die gibt es alle.
Ich habe letztens einen guten Film gesehen,
der hieß
hui,
Letters oder irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung.
Boah. Och, Alter. Vor allem, wenn man dieses, das ist ja auch irgendwo, also Leute hören uns ja auch, haben eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung an die Unterhaltung und so weiter. Und ich finde es auch dann teilweise schwierig, wenn man sagt, wir machen das zu einem gewissen Grad auch professionell, und dann finde ich, musst du, wenn du in die Filmkritik-Rubrik rutscht, auch aus Versehen, meinetwegen, musst du den Titel des Films parat haben. Ja, ja, stimmt schon. Call me a party pooper, but ich finde, wir sollten das zumindest machen. Meinst du, wir machen diesen Podcast auch noch, wenn wir 90 und dement sind und einfach die gesamte, und einfach die gleiche Geschichte 30 Mal erzählen, ist jetzt schon so. Ist jetzt schon so. St so. Was ändert sich, außer dass wir mehr wissen übers Leben? Was ich nur sagen wollte, ist, dieser Film hat einen Soundtrack von Philip Glass. Philip Glass kann man drüber denken, was man möchte. Die Truman Show. Ich glaube, der ist einfach, glaube ich, berüchtigt dafür, dass er extrem repetitive Musik macht. So, und das ist ja okay, das kann man ja auch machen. Aber ich saß in diesem Film und ich wurde wirklich innerlich immer, immer wütender, weil der Soundtrack einfach und das wirklich über 30 Minuten und es erstickt auch jede Emotion.
Du hast, weißt du, die Figuren sind gerade traurig, Verfolgungsjagd, nichts, es ändert sich nichts, es ist einfach Tanzszene. Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du- sehr eintönigen Soundtrack. Ich weiß nicht, zum Beispiel Paul Thomas Anderson hat auch manchmal sehr monotone, der hat dann wirklich einfach nur so zwei Töne, du, du, du, du, du,
und das ist wirklich sehr lange, aber da ist es irgendwie,
dadurch, dass es so repetitiv ist,
wieder ein Stilmittel und es
fällt auf als, oh, das fällt jetzt
irgendwie auf, aber Filmglasmusik geht einfach so
unter und ich glaube, was immer ein schlechtes
Zeichen für einen Filmsoundtrack ist,
ist, wenn man sich während des Films
denkt,
ich hab da noch einen Tab offen, oder? Das kann doch nicht sein, dass es vom Film kommt. Du guckst keinen Tapoffen und schaust weiter. Da merkt man einfach, und da muss ich auch mal ein Filmglas, die Rückmeldung geben, das war nix, dieser Film The Letters, glaube ich, Three Letters oder so was in der Richtung. Umgekehrt bin ich meistens mit dem Tapoffen, ganz ehrlich gesagt. In dem Mai, 80 % der Fälle, hab ich einen Tap-offen. Ich hab auch Taps offen. Aber ich find's gut, manche Browser zeigen oben dieses Lautsprechersymbol an, wo man sagt, ein Tap-Ball hat hier gerade einen. Wo ich immer das Gefühl hab, so ein bisschen Snitch-Browser. Du gehst aus dem Vollbild raus und sagst, Leute, wer redet hier, wer schwätzt, und der Browser, der da, da hier, hier, der Tap. So alle anderen Tabs zeigen auf ihn, alle Finger in die Richtung. Oh, er redet. Was, nein! Früher haben die zusammengehalten, früher musstest du dich durch jeden einzelnen Tab klicken, bis du den Übelteller gefunden hast. Bist du ein Tab-Closer oder bist du ein Tab-Off-offenlasser? Nee, Tab-Messi, Tab-Messi. Hab ich mir schon gedacht, ich hab ein sehr sortierter Tab. Manchmal hab ich aus Versehen noch ein anderes Fenster offen. Nee, das nie. Das passiert manchmal. Das nie. Aber ich bin bei Tabs immer sehr sortiert. Ich habe immer ganz viele Tabs of shame. Ich habe, glaube ich, generell so um die zehn Artikel offen. So auf Twitter, du scrollst euch Twitter, ah, interessanter Artikel. Mit der Intention, nochmal zurückzukehren, oder hast du die einfach offen gelassen? Einfach, um mich für einen belesenen, weltgewandten Menschen zu halten. Ah, Artikel, warum die EU kurz vorm Ende ist. Tab öffnen, nie lesen. Aber unterbewusst, weil du noch mal zurückkommen willst? Ja, natürlich, weil ich mir denke, irgendwann lese ich den noch. Nie, ich weiss es nicht mehr. Das ist ein Todesurteil für einen Artikel. Wenn man einen extra Tab geöffnet ist, vergiss es. Dann sollte da Musik angehen. Hey, ich bin noch an. Ja, das stimmt. Oder er wird immer größer, dass der Tab immer größer wird mit der Zeit, sodass er irgendwann wirklich, dass du ihn nicht mehr ignorieren kannst, einfach, dass er so zehn Zentimeter lang ist, er denkst, ja gut, lese ich die zehn Punkte, warum du zur Europawahl gehen wolltest, nächsten Sonntag geht wählen, oh gut, lese ich es halt. Und dann wies man es aus schlechtem Gewissen. Wählt mal, bitte. Ich habe Briefwahl begangen und habe diesen Wahlzeiten bekommen. Soll man denn nicht wegen der Umwelt? Ja, wirklich? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es eigentlich nicht. Obwohlwohl ich nicht gar nicht weiß, ich habe noch nicht abgeschickt. Ich habe bis jetzt nur gewählt und gesteckt. Mir gefällt der Begriff aber soll man nicht. Soll man nicht? Sag ich einfach ganz gern. Einfach mal, ich glaube auch, die meisten Leute, die sagen, das soll man ja gar nicht mehr machen, haben keine Ahnung, die wollen gerade mal was sagen. Pass mal auf, das sind meistens die Leute, die seit zehn Minuten an dem Gespräch sonst nichts beigetragen haben. Ja, ja. Vor allem, niemand wird ja fragen, hä, warum nicht? Weil man muss ja dann die akzeptable Reaktion sagen, ja stimmt, aber ich mache es ja auch immer selten. Und das klingt auch wie ein Gesetz, wie so ein soziales Gesetz, soll man nicht mehr, als hätten das heute beschlossen. Aber du hast Briefwahl begangen. Nee, nee, ich habe jetzt in meinem Zimmer meine Couch und den Sessel gewechselt, weil irgendwie stand die Couch immer an der Front mit den Fenstern und dann hatte ich irgendwie, wenn ich was gelesen habe, hat mich immer die Sonne geblendet. Nee, das soll man nicht mehr so machen. Ja, ich weiß schon, klar, es ist nicht gut, aber ich habe es jetzt noch einmal gemacht und jetzt ist es gleich. Ich weiß schon, das ist, nee, es tut mir leid. Man soll aber auch nicht die ganze Zeit so wie ein Mann mit dem Kopf schütteln, wie du es gerade machst. Ja, es tut mir leid, es ist schlecht für ein Mann. Man soll sich aber auch nicht so oft entschuldigen, das soll man nicht. Soll man, man soll das nicht. Man soll auch so laut nicht atmen, das ist für Leute, die oben herum anstrengt. Und so blau anlaufen soll man auch nicht. Man soll, es ist auch für Impro schwierig, diese soll man nicht. Ich habe gewählt, und es ist natürlich nicht einfach? Es ist natürlich einfach, sich über die ganzen Parteien lustig zu machen.
Weil du hast diese, es ist wirklich wie so ein Comedy-Moment.
Du machst diesen Zettel so auf und dann siehst du halt CDU, SPD, Grüne, Die Linke.
Und dann machst du den zweiten und dann fällt dieses Papier so auf und ist ein zehn Meter langes Papier,
das sich so wie die nackte Kanone einmal durch die gesamte Wohnung... Man will so sagen, fatter Lords, fatter Ladies! Ja. Weil es wirkt so wie diese langen Comedy-Fetteln. Hurt, hurt! Hurt, hurt! Es wirkt so ein bisschen so, als würde man jetzt so eine Rede verlieren. Und gleich kommt, da unten steht dann, und jetzt der schwarze Ritter! Aber es ist tatsächlich nur ein Wahlzettel. Es ist ein Wahlzettel und ich habe schon die Feder in Tinte getunkt, meine Gänsefeder in Tintenfischtinte getunkt, um dann ein ganz... Und es fühlt sich gut an, dieses offizielle Kreuz zu machen, so dieses, ja, das ist es.
Und dann ausserlich nur das zweite Kreuz.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber verrückte Parteien, es gibt vier verschiedene Tierschutzparteien, wo man einfach sagt, Leute, reißt euch mal zusammen.
Wie viele Tintiere gibt es überhaupt noch? Man hört doch immer, dass alle ausgestorben sind.
Also ich kann schon verstehen, dass sich ein gemeinsamer politischer Wille nicht immer in der direkten Partei ausdrücken kann und man spaltet sich dann halt irgendwann. Aber eine Tierschutzpartei sollte ja relativ straightforward sein. Worüber können die noch streiten? Über welches Thema spalten die sich? Weil normalerweise, wenn du sagst, keine Ahnung, wir sind jetzt im sozialen Mindestlohn, dann sagen die, wir wollen Mindestlohn 11 Euro, die anderen sagen Mindestlohn 10 Euro, dann sagt gut, lassen wir es, wir spalten uns, jeder macht seine eigene Partei.
Die Elber, aber auch das ist meistens kein Grund. Aber ja, auch da sind meistens sehr grundsätzliche Differenzen, aber bei Tierschutzpartei gebe ich dir schon recht.
Und ich finde auch mal, dass die Bienenschutzpartei, die soll dich mal zusammenspielen, brauchst du extra, oder können die nicht einfach sagen, ja, Bienen sind auch Tiere. Wir können uns auch zu einer Tierschutzpartei, die honignahe Tierschutzpartei. Es ist eigentlich eine Ein-Prozent-Partei, wenn man sich so überlegt. Die Bienen sind ein Prozent aller Tiere. Es ist eine Elitenpartei. Die Bienenpartei ist eine Elitenpartei. Ist das eine These? Die Bienen sind doch im Prinzip unterm Strich ein Prozent aller Tiere? Das ist eine Zweitiergesellschaft. Du kannst ja nicht einfach die Bienen an die erste Stelle machen, nur weil die arbeiten, und die anderen Tiere, die nicht arbeiten, sind weniger wert, oder was? Was ist das für eine Anschauung? Kannst du ja nicht machen. Das soll man vielleicht auch nicht erzählen, aber eine Biologiestudentin hat mir, pardon, Medizinstudentin, ich muss im kommenden genauer bleiben. Du hast vier Stunden mit ihr gesprochen, Stefan. Pardon, Humanmedizinstudentin hat gesagt, sie hat, ihr Biologieprofessor hat ihr gesagt, dass Bienensterben wäre gar keine große Sache. Man hat das entdeckt, dass es gar nicht der Fall ist und deswegen, aber niemand will es sagen, weil es schon ein Problem ist, dass sie sterben. es ist keine Riesensache mehr, aber niemand der Wissenschaftler will sagen, hey, das ist uns gar kein Problem, weil dann Menschen wahrscheinlich dumme Sachen machen.
Ja.
Und irgendwie, ich habe auch gesagt, das sollte ich vielleicht auch nie weitererzählen.
Und deswegen wollte ich es auch Podcast lustigerweise nie erzählen, weil...
Weil jetzt alle ihre Bienen umbringen.
Ja, weil jetzt... Es stimmt schon, kein Wissenschaftler würde sagen, Leute, schützt die Bienen weniger.
Ja, genau. Und dann würden Menschen wieder überkompensieren. Es ist eine Einbahnstrasse, es ist einfach nur eine Einbahnstrasse. Ich denke mir zum Beispiel auch so was wie, keine Ahnung, so, irgendjemand muss sich ja entscheiden, wie viele Jahre Gefängnisstrafe
gibt es für zum Beispiel Vergewaltigung.
Irgendjemand musste diese Zahl festlegen.
Und ich denke mir, diese Zahl
kann ja, es gibt ja irgendwo eine gerechte,
optimale gerechte Zahl, ganz abstrakt,
und es gibt die tatsächliche Zahl, die wir
gefunden haben als unser Rechtssystem.
Aber diese Zahl kann ja nie wieder
verkleinert werden. Es kann ja
kein Politiker hingehen und sagen, Freunde, von zehn auf neun bitte. Das ist ja unmöglich. Das ist weniger schlimm geworden. Vielleicht, wenn es sehr viele andere schlimmere Straftaten gibt. Dass es dann so eine Reform gibt. Wo man irgendwann sagt, jetzt rutscht alles, alle Strafverrutschen mal einen runter. Nee, weil du kannst nur sagen, keine Ahnung, jetzt sagen, ah, keine Ahnung, verbrennt die Vergewaltiger und die Kinderschänder, die sollen doppelt so lange Strafe bekommen. Da würden Leute für die Stimmen so irgendwie, ja, mit harter Faust gegen die Vorgehen. Aber wenn jemand sagt, nee, halbe Strafe, macht niemand. Das ist unmöglich, dass diese Strafe sich verringert. Außer, jetzt erreichen jetzt die Raper eine grosse ... Wenn die jetzt sehr viele ... Raper? Raper. Ach, Raper. Rapists. Okay. Wenn die jetzt einen sehr grossen Anteil in der Weltbevölkerung einnehmen würden, dass ich dann auch so eine Schlitterpartei bin, die dann irgendwann gefährlich viele Stimmen bekommt, da kann ich mich schon vorstellen, dass die man irgendwann dafür stimmen. Das stimmt und das sind die zwei Dinge, die eine Einbahnstrasse sind, Bienenschutz und Strafe für Vergewaltigung. Die gehen nur noch in eine Richtung, nur wieder zurück. Aber darf man im Gefängnis davon wählen, oder? Auch schon, ne? Ähm, oh, das weiß ich gar nicht. Klar, natürlich. Ne, ab einem gewissen Punkt wird ja auch dein Wahlrecht entzogen. Nein, glaub ich nicht. Bin ich mir sehr sicher. Ich glaube nur, wenn du irgendwie unzurechnungsfähig bist oder irgendwas. Ne, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, an einem gewissen Punkt wird dein Wahlrecht entzogen. Ja, aber das ist ja, da kannst du ja einfach die Leute, die du nicht magst, einsperren. Und dann dürfen die nicht mehr wählen. Ne, du kannst die Leute einfach einsperren. Ja, wenn du aber jetzt irgendwie ein super autoritärer Staat bist. Nee, so funktioniert die Welt nicht, Laurentin. Wahlrecht. Doch, okay. Stefan, so weit ist es gekommen. Stefan kugelt. Stefan tippt gelangweilt mit seiner linken Hand. So wichtig ist ihm die Demokratie. Das ist wirklich das Gift für Demokratie. Stefan Tietze, Popcorn-Krümel auf dem Bauch. Wahlrecht endet nicht im Gefängnis. So! Das passive Wahlrecht, ich lese es aber so vor, als hätte ich recht. Ich lese es so vor, als hätte ich recht. Wahlrecht endet nicht im Gefängnis. Das passive Wahlrecht verlieren Inhaftierte für fünf Jahre, wenn sie zu einer Strafe von mindestens einem Jahr ohne Bewährung verursacht werden. Sie verlieren es für fünf Jahre? Grundsätzlich verfügen sie allerdings über das aktive Wahlrecht, ja, das passive ist aktive. Das passive heißt, du darfst gewählen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich will nicht auf den Link klicken, um es herauszufinden. Also das aktive verlieren Sie nicht. So viel mit Demokratie bin ich bereit einzugehen, aber zwischen mir und der Demokratie steht ein Link. Aber aktive Wahlrecht verlieren Sie nie. Nee. Aber passives schon. Ja. Aber das ist ja auch sinnvoll, du kannst ja schlecht Bundestagsabgeordneter sein, wenn du im Gefängnis bist. Mir gefallen diese Fragen, die Google jetzt... So ein Mann Käfig steht dann im Bundestag. Er darf dann nicht raus. Mir gefallen diese kleinen Fragen, die jetzt eingeblendet werden, die noch dazu passen, von Google. Was sind die Wahlgrundsätze? Haben Gefängnisinsassen Wahlrecht? Was versteht man unter dem passiven Wahlrecht, oh, kann man auch direkt drauf, das aktive Wahlrecht ist das Recht eines Menschen, sich in einer staatlichen oder nicht staatlichen Wahl durch Stimmabgabe beteiligen zu können, also zu wählen. Passiv heisst, du darfst gewählt werden. Wer das aktive Wahlrecht besitzt, wird als wahlberechtigt bezeichnet. Aber auch hier steht wieder zwischen mir und dem Wissen ein Link, auf den ich nicht bereit bin zu klicken. Wann wurde das Wahlalter von 21 auf 18 gesenkt? Lohnt ihn? Oh, äh, seit 72. 69. Knapp, ganz knapp. Bist du dafür, das Wahlalter zu senken auf 16? Ähm, ich meine, wir hatten unsere Praktikantin Thais, die war da, und ich sag mal so, die war politisch engagierter als ich. Ja. Muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Muss man sagen. Ich meine, es ist natürlich die Frage, klar, so diese Fridays for Future, ich will nicht sagen, dass das alles Heuchler sind, aber viel ist wahrscheinlich auch so, ja, wir gehen da hin und machen Party und haben keine Schule. Nicht, dass alle machen, überhaupt nicht. Ich sag nur nicht, jeder, der auf diese Veranstaltungen geht, ist automatisch super politikengagiert. 16 fände ich okay. Darunter alles fände ich schwierig, glaube ich. Soll Thais wählen dürfen? Ja, oder man macht so Tests. Wahlberechtigt. Wenn du die richtige Partei wählen würdest. Nur wenn du gut sehen kannst. Wenn du die richtigen Parteien wählen würdest, dann darfst du wählen. Das. Das wäre mein Vorschlag. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ja. Nee, und ich glaube, das schon ab 16 wäre schon okay. 15? Weiß ich nicht. 14? Wo machst du den Strich? Bei 16. Bei älteren Menschen sollte man manchmal Tests durchführen, ob die noch zurechnungsfähig sind. Ab und zu. Weil da wählen auch Menschen, wo ich... So einen Ball zuwerfen bei der Stimmeaufgabe. Ja genau, und gucken, ob die den noch fangen können. Wenn sie ihn fangen können, dürfen sie wählen. Oder einmal so diesen Wetten-das-Test machen. So vor die Augen. Man merkt, da geht gar nichts mehr. Ich meine, Wahlen sind ja ohnehin oft in Schulen. Da kann man dann einfach so einen Basketballkorb aufbauen. Und jeder Rentner muss drei Freiwürfe werden. Wer hat 70 Würfe? Sagen wir mal, weil es ist ja auch, es geht ja mehr um den Versuch. Jeder hat 120 Würfe und wenn man mehr als die Hälfte trifft, darf man wählen. Und das ab 80. Und man darf auch nah am Korb stehen. Ja, das stimmt. Und man darf auch so Dribbelfehler machen. Das ist okay. Das ist okay. Das ist kein Problem. Drei Schritte mehr. Und dann hast du die ganzen Sportlehrer, die kommen dann hin und die prüfen das dann und dann irgendwie, Erna, wirft dann, ah, leider nicht getroffen. Was wäre eine Gesellschaftsform, für die du wärst? Weil manchmal überlege ich so, es gibt vielleicht bessere Ideen als Demokratie. Glaubst du, wir schaffen es in diesem Podcast eine Gesellschaftsform zu finden, die besser ist als alles, was wir bis jetzt hatten? Ja, das ist unser Ziel, für Folge 1000 oder sowas. Ja, lass uns mal langfristig daran arbeiten. Folge 1000 haben wir eine bessere Gesellschaftsform. Ja. Regel 1? Wir spalten die Erde in zwei grosse Länder. Ein Land ist zu wenig. Wenn du ein Land hast, bist du faul, Monopolstellung. Du spaltest die Welt in zwei grosse Länder. Konkurrenz zwei Länder. Russland und USA. Gut, zwei Sprachen, sagen wir mal lettisch oder russisch und englisch. Okay, so. Und dann gibst du beiden, jeder hat so 1000 Euro.
Jeder hat so 1000 Euro. Und dann guckst du nach einem Jahr, welches Land hat sich besser angestellt mit dem Geld.
Also wer hat irgendwie in Schulen investiert und wer hat irgendwie Panzer gebaut und so. Dann tötest du alle Menschen aus dem Land, was weniger aus dem Geld gemacht hat. Und dann die Hälfte des Gewinners zieht dann wieder in den Bereich des Verlierers. Oh, wir haben gerade die Gesellschaftsformen von Thanos aus Avengers propagiert. Du musst sie ja nicht umringen, du musst sie nur so eingraben oder so, dass sie halt nichts mehr machen können. Die müssen ja nicht sterben, nur dass du sie halt dann irgendwo in so ein Loch wirfst. Wäre es nicht eine Idee, die Hälfte der Gesellschaft unfruchtbar zu machen? Ja, damit... Gute Idee, gute Serie Utopia. Habe ich nie gesehen. Aber da geht es genau darum. darum. Ach, das hast du mal erzählt. Überbevölkerung und die Bösewichte sozusagen wollen ein geheimes Gift entwickeln. Ich dachte gerade, das wäre eine mega Idee, weil du bringst ja niemanden um. Ja, das stimmt schon. Sondern du schaffst einfach langfristig mehr Platz auf der Welt. Klar, du machst manche Menschen, schränkst du schon sehr ein im Leben, weil sie nicht mehr die Wahl treffen können, Kinder zu bekommen. Auf der anderen Seite hast du danach, denkst du, also die Zukunft, die Erde überlebt, Tiere überleben, weniger, du hast mehr Platz, das Phantasialand ist immer leer, Parkplätze sind frei. Ja, oder kleinere Menschen. Ich habe jetzt überlegt, weil ich habe jetzt... Downsizing, wie in dem Bruder war für ein Downsizing. Ich habe mir jetzt eine Rolle bestellt. Eine Faszienrolle. Was sind Faszien? Nee, ich habe mir einen Faszienball bestellt. Ja? Nee, ich dachte, ich gehe direkt Next Level und hole mir die Faszienrolle. Zylinder schlägt Kugel, wissen wir beide. Und das ist dazu da, dass man seinen Rücken irgendwie wieder einrenkt oder in Ordnung kriegt. Wieder herstellt. Weil wir alle sitzen viel und deswegen haben wir alle Rückenschmerzen. Aber ich habe mir gedacht, und jetzt gibt es auch, hat mir heute jemand erzählt, dass es so eine Art Hosenträger gibt, die man aber hinten an der Hose befestigt und dann irgendwie ziehen die deine Schulter so zurück. Oh, ist das der nächste modische Schritt? Dass du generell aufrechter gehst. Ja, so ein Korsett gibt es auch, was du einfach so umschnallen kannst. Im Grunde schon, ja. Aber da dachte ich mir, eigentlich steht man da doch dem evolutionären Fortschritt im Weg. Eigentlich ist der Mensch doch jetzt an einem Punkt, wo er sagt... Floating Heads. Floating Heads, wir verarbeiten uns weit. Ganz so weit wollte ich doch nicht gehen, du hast mich ein bisschen mitgerissen. Ich glaube, Politik ist deine Sache, Stefan. Nee, weil du gerade wirklich beeindruckt warst. Du hast so beeinflusst, dass du direkt mitpropagiert hast. Nee, ich dachte mir, der Rücken, also ich meine, der... Du solltest vielleicht aus den Medien raus. Das ist gefährlich. Ja, das stimmt. Wenn du so beeinflusst warst, Floating Heads, Körper ab. Jeder kriegt den Kopf ab, in Glas, perfekt. Und auch der, der dich beeinflusst hat, denkt so, okay, alles klar, slow down, man. Nee, ich glaube, der Mensch hat ja auf dem Boden gestartet, so als, was heisst ich, Schildkröte oder so. Und dann aufrechter Gang und jetzt geht es wieder so auf dem Boden zurück, dass man so kopfüber läuft. Und warum sollte man diese evolutionäre Entwicklung aufhalten? Weil wir haben noch Rückenschmerzen. In tausend Generationen ist deren Körper so oft das Sitzen angepasst. Es ist nämlich, da will ich dir wieder sprechen, weil ich habe das Reklam-Büchchen zur Evolution gelesen, es ist nämlich keine evolutionäre Entwicklung, dass der Mensch jetzt der Rücken kaputt geht. Nein. Eben nicht, aber der menschliche Körper ist ja fürs aufrechte Gehen gemacht. Aber der moderne Mensch geht ja nicht mehr so viel aufrecht, sondern sitzt den ganzen Tag und lehnt sich über aus seiner Xbox-Connect und seinem Candy-Crush und so. Ja, aber das ist ja keine evolutionäre Entwicklung. Nee, das ist eine gesellschaftliche Entwicklung. Aber der Körper muss sich dem wieder anpassen. Ach so. Ich meine, gut, es ist natürlich schwer zu sagen, wo trennt man jetzt evolutionär und sozial. Ich meine, du kannst ja auch sagen, sowas wie Monogamie, ist das Evolution oder ist das sozial? Ist es nicht so, dass wir Rückenschmerzen haben, weil unsere Körper eben nicht für den aufrechten Gang gemacht sind? Es ist nicht einfach ... Unser Gehirn ist doch eine Fehlbildung, unser Gehirn ist doch eine Riesenmutation. Man sagt, eigentlich, unsere Körper hinken ja nur nach, unsere Hüllen hinken unserem grossen Hirn ja nur nach. Ja. Weil eigentlich ist der Körper nicht für den aufrechten Gang gemacht. Der Mensch ist nur so schlau geworden, dass der Körper irgendwie denkt, fuck, fuck, wir müssen aufholen, das Hirn will irgendwo hin. Ja gut, aber wenn du so argumentierst... Es steht ein Lebensstil an, unser Körper muss nachkommen, deswegen Floating Heads. Aber wenn du so argumentierst, ist kein Lebewesen dafür gemacht, was es ist. Weil jedes Lebewesen hat sich aus irgendwas anderem entwickelt. Dann sagst du auch, das Huhn ist auch nicht dafür gedacht, dass es kein Dinosaurier mehr ist, sondern es will eigentlich noch Dinosaurier sein. Weil du bist ja, irgendwas hängt ja immer hinterher. Nur was strebt, bei uns strebt das Gehirn, das ist der aktive Part. Ja, wirklich? Ich habe eher das gegenteilige Gefühl. Dein Körper strebt. Das Gehirn will wieder zurück. Nee, mein Gehirn will Dinge machen und mein Körper sagt, ne Backe, sagt mein Körper. Au Backe. Und mein Gehirn sagt, nee, komm. Und dann ist es auch ein Problem, deswegen denke ich mir, Floating Heads, einfach schön so eine Glaskuppel mit Helium gefüllt, da drin ist das Gehirn, und es schwebt rum. Und in meinem Kopf habe ich so, wie so Stephen Hawking-mäßig, kann ich so, ich muss denken, vorne, zurück, oben, unten, und mein Gehirn schwebt. Ich brauche kein Essen. Du bist nur noch Gehirn, nicht nur mehr Kopf. Ein bisschen so Bubble aus Helium, da drin ist eine, es schwebt quasi. Ja. Ich weiß noch nicht genau, wie es aussieht. Auf jeden Fall so Glaskugeln, da drin ist unser Gehirn konserviert, und vorne sind so Namensschilder drauf. Und ein Auge oder so. Ein Auge nur noch. Ein Auge reicht ja völlig. Und das ist dann aber auch, das ist dann, das rennt dann so 3D und dann kannst du gucken und dann, es reicht aber ein so eine Kamera und dann flottest du so durch die Welt. Ja. Und alles andere machen dann so Extensions für uns. Und dann, wir sitzen gerade im Cuttingraum, da kannst du einfach dich an so eine Cuttingstation reinhängen und dann hast du so Roboterarme und die machen das dann für dich. Du musst nur denken, die Dinge. Das ist auch die Zukunft. Ja, und wenn dir mal der Löffel runterfällt? Hm? Wovoraufst du einen Löffel? Was willst du denn essen? Du bist ein Gehirn. Ja, und wenn dann irgendwie deine, wenn du dich dann aus Versehen so drehst? Du musst dich nie mehr drehen. Nie mehr musst du dich drehen. Ja, aber wenn du jetzt mal aus Versehen, du machst so ein aus Versehen so ein Rückwärtssalto und die ganze Flüssigkeit läuft raus und du wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Ja, das ist einer von genau, von den 0,5% Toten, die es da noch gibt. Die ein Salto machen. Die ein Salto machen, die ein Salto versuchen. Salto-Attempt. Das ist dann ein typischer Salto-Attempt, ein SA, so und dann kommt dann so ein Notarzt, Gehirne angefahren, die dein Gehirn dann wegtragen und dann dann fühlen sich die Schildkröne, die so auf dem Rücken liegt, eines Glas und Glas ist umgefallen oder falsch. Zwei Ärmchen, wedeln wild. Ja, das ist aber eine gute Idee. Gibt es da eine Partei, die man wählen kann? Ja, Floating Head Partei. FHP? FHP, FHP von Stefan Thiese. Könnt ihr mich gerne wählen, die Floating Head Partei. Und dann ist auch diese ganze lästige Instagram-Scheisse, die ganze oberflächliche Kacke. Niemand fotografiert sein Gehirn mehr, weil das einfach ein hässliches Gebilde. Darum geht es ja gar nicht mehr. Es geht um diese ganze Oberflächlichkeit verlieren wir. Es geht nur noch um Inhalte, es geht nur noch um Floating-Heads. Um Content, um Content. Um Content, ja. Nur noch Content-Fabriken. Wir sind der lustigste, contentreichste Planet dann. Aber ich glaub, du hast schon Recht, sich schrumpfen zu lassen und ist schon sehr, sehr zukunftsträchtig. Also, weil es Ressourcen dann automatisch potenziert, wenn wir alle kleiner wären. Wir bräuchten nur noch kleine Flugzeuge, die fliegen, von A nach B usw. Weiß ich nicht. Das würd ich gern zurücknehmen. Ich glaub, der wichtigste Schritt ist ... Vor Aliens würde uns dann ... weil da wollte ich nur aus Aliens kommen dann und finden uns nicht. Das würde ich gerne zurücknehmen. Ich glaube, der wichtigste Schritt ist, kürzere Aliens würden uns dann, da wollte ich nur aus Aliens kommen dann und finden uns nicht, weil wir so klein sind dann. Und vielleicht denken wir, wir sind ja ein bisschen Planeten. Auf dem Mond ist vielleicht so ein kleiner, ein kleiner Menschenvolk. Aber vielleicht sind Aliens ohnehin schon riesengroß und für die sind wir jetzt schon sehr klein. Ich glaube, vortrittliche Aliens sind, wie wir sagen, sehr klein oder Floating Heads. dass unser Planet ist für die nur so ein Tennisball. Und dann, wie sollen wir jetzt ein Raumschiff bauen, das auf einen Tennisball fliegt? Wir sind zu gross. Aber warum sollten die gross sein? Warum sollten die genauso gross sein wie wir? Ist doch viel unwahrscheinlicher, dass sie so gross sind wie wir, als dass sie eine andere grössere. Das mein ich auch. Ich mein nur, je fortschrittlicher das Volk, desto kleiner ist es wahrscheinlich. Wirklich? Weil die es geschafft haben, sich zu kleiner zu machen. Weil das ist cleverer, um die Ressourcen eines Planeten besser auszunutzen. Ja, aber wenn du gross bist, kannst du mehr Bienen retten. Ich sag dir, die Bienen sind riesig bei denen, die Bienen sind riesig, aber selber sind es nur ganz kleine Floating Heads. Ja, die haben es versaut. Die haben es versaut mit der Skalierung. Und dann übernehmen irgendwann die Bienen, weil die sich denken, ihr Trottel, ihr habt uns zu groß gemacht und habt euch so klein gemacht. Die Gehirne der Bienen sind zu groß, am Ende bleiben Bienen über. Vielleicht war das schon so. Vielleicht waren die Bienen mal die Menschen und wir die Bienen. Und die Bienen wurden immer kleiner und wir wurden immer größer. Und jetzt haben wir die Kontrolle übernommen. Und jetzt mit den Bienensterben. Und die Bienen, what the fuck. Ja, und die haben es jetzt versaut und jetzt kommen die wieder. Weil jetzt ist ein ewiger Kreislauf. Weil die uns manipulieren mit ihrem Bienensterben ja und die haben es jetzt versaut und jetzt kommen die wieder, weil jetzt es ist ein ewiger Kreislauf weil die uns manipulieren mit ihrem Bienensterben und der selbere Professor von einer Freundin von mir hat jetzt herausgefunden, es gibt kein Bienensterben stimmt, das ist der Held eigentlich der Geschichte und wir Idioten, wir rennen alle den Bienen hinterher mit unserem willenlosen mit unserer Ideologie mit unseren hängenden Körpern mein Körper ist ist wie diese grossen Bälle an Heftlingen aus Western-Comics. Diese grossen Bälle, die die haben. Fussfesseln, sagt man auch. Mein Körper ist ein Fussfessel meines Gehirns. Mein Gehirn will in die Welt, aber mein Körper sagt, boah, nee, nee, erst mal sitzen.
Lass uns hier mal hinsetzen auf diese Bank hier. Lass mal sitzen und nichts tun. Einfach mal sitzen. Und da fallen die Augen zu. Es ist wie so ein, dein Gehirn ist wie so ein siamesischer Zwilling, der nicht zu dem Körper gehört und denkt, boah, schon wieder Park, ey. Ja, was will er hier? Was will er hier? Oder auch so, wie Stewardess die sagt, und dann gehen die Augen zu und der Kopf sagt so, hey, hey, ich will noch gucken. Okay, Augen hat er zugemacht. Und dann wie die Stewardess, die sagt, jetzt will die Sonnenblenden runter. Und ich sage, aber ich will noch rausgucken. Ich habe oft das Problem, ich liege im Bett und kann nicht schlafen und denke mir, was ist hier eigentlich gerade los? Warum kann ich nicht schlafen? Hallo, hallo, hört mich jemand? Kann ich kurz hier mal irgendwie den Vorgesetzten sprechen? Weil ich will schlafen, der Körper will schlafen, aber er schläft nicht. Warum nicht? Was passiert hier? Ja, das und da ist dann, ja. Wer kämpft hier gerade gegen wen? Dein Gehirn kämpft gegen deinen Körper, das ist, was ich sage die ganze Zeit. Gehirn ist ja irgendwo dein Körper. Tritt der FAP dazu. Ja, echt, okay Okay, okay. Warum drehen sich deine Augen so schnell? Was sind das für Strahlen, die da rauskommen? Okay, ich wähle die FAP. Kann ich eigentlich, ich habe jetzt meinen Wahlzettel schon ausgefüllt und eingesteckt. Kann ich das nochmal korrigieren? Kannst du anrufen und sagen, ich würde lieber jetzt die FAP wählen. Floating Head-Partei Stefan. Wie ist dein Name? Florentin Will. Okay, mit H. Jupp, passt. Haben wir gemacht. Ja, ja. Sorry. Das hat meine Welt zerstört, als ich herausgefunden habe, dass Wahlen nur Hochrechnungen sind. Und im Endeffekt wird ja gar nicht mehr gezählt. Nach zehn Zetteln wissen die schlauen Asiaten, die in dem Rechenraum sitzen, wissen genau, was... Ein FAP, einmal kommunistische Partei, 50-50! Komm, wir gehen heim! Schauen Sie uns Game of Thrones an. Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es so. Oder gibt es noch Wahlen, wo alle Zettel gewählt werden? Oder ist es nachträglich, wo alle Zettel gewählt werden? Nee, du darfst tatsächlich, du hast als Bürger das Recht, bei der Wahlauszählung zuzuschauen. Du darfst hingehen und zugucken, wie die das auswählen. Und dann sitzen die Leute da und denken sich, Leute, wir sind ehrenamtliche, freiwillige Helfer. Wenn ihr schon hier seid, können sie dir auch mithelfen? Nö, ich bin nur hier im Zug zugucken. Machen wir da. Sie haben da einen vergessen, da hinten liegt noch einer. Da hinten! Was steht hier drauf? Ja, komm, AfD, passt schon, passt schon, kein Wobbel. Ich glaube,
wieso kann man Wahlen manipulieren?
Das dachte ich mir nämlich auch zum Beispiel,
also was muss passieren, damit eine Wahl ungültig
ist, weil ich denke mir immer so, ich gebe jetzt den
meinen Wahl, meinen Briefwahlzettel
an meinen Kiosk
und dann sagt der, oh, man erkennt die ja, das sind ja so
pinke Umschläge und der sagt, nö,
der wählt bestimmt eine Scheißpartei,
werfe ich weg. Und die Brief kommt nicht an. Und dann irgendwann nach der Wahl rede ich mit dem und sage, du, wie war das eigentlich mit meinem Briefwahlzettel, wie man so macht? Und er sagt, ne, habe ich weggeworfen. Kann ich dann sagen, nee, nochmal Wahlrückgängig, weil meine Stimme kommt nicht an. Plus eins für die FAP, bitte. Nee, dann geht das eine große Neuwahl. Dann kommt Tagesschau, weil Florentin Will seinen Zettel nicht richtig abgeschicken konnte. Na, er weiß nicht genau, was dann passiert. Ich glaube, es braucht schon viele Leute, oder? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber ich meine, es gibt doch, wer muss denn sagen, dass er die Wahl wiederholt haben will? Weil wenn alle Parteien zufrieden sind mit dem Ergebnis, würde ja niemand sagen, nee, wir wollen nochmal wiederholen. Ausser die eine, die Tierschutzpartei Nummer zwei, die zweite Tier-, die ZTSP, ZTSP, zweite Tierschutzpartei, die sagt, nee, wir zweifeln die Wahl an. Und dann kommen die Angeritten auf ihren Pferden. Nach Berlin reiten die an. Oh Gott, da kommt die ZWFP! Dann kommen die Bienenpartei, da werden Bienen angeflogen und dann gibt's einen Krieg. Bei dem Tiere zu Schaden kommen werden, das entspricht nicht eurer Ideologie. Das stimmt eigentlich. Du kriegst nämlich eine Nachrichtigung, ob dein Briefwahl angekommen ist oder nicht. Ah, das kann sein. Du kriegst nochmal eine Wahlbericht und Nachrichtigung, wenn du zur Wahl kommen musst. Und wenn du richtig gewählt hast. Ja, ein großes Dankeschön und Gutschein für H&M. Du hast völlig recht, ich finde auch, die Tierschutzpartei sollte nicht länger Tiere zu Kampfzwecken einsetzen, weil dadurch die gefährdet werden. Klar, Revolution fordert immer Opfer, wissen wir alle. Aber müssen sie jetzt auf Riesen Bienen angeflogen kommen? Das wäre ein geiler Auftritt. Ja, ja, schon klar. Man sagt, die Hannelore Kraft kommt einfach zu ihrem Wahllokal gelaufen und gibt sich eine Stimme, Sigmar Gabriel kommt angerollt, er gibt sich eine Stimme und dann kommt die Tierschutzpartei-Vorsitzende auf so einem Schwarm mit so einem Schwarm-Wespmann. Wie so Daenerys dann angewärts. Das wäre geil. Steht irgendwo, dass man keine Biene wählen darf. Und dann kommt der Dino-Parteityp auf so einem Terranodon angeflogen. Das ist ja immer fett. Ich glaube, so etwas gab es auch mal. Und dann gab es irgendwie so ein Gesetz, dass keine Tiere im Bundestag erlaubt sind, weil alle hier mit ihrem Pferd oder mit ihrem Eisbären oder so unterwegs waren. Wissen wir mit Sicherheit, dass Dinosaurier dumm waren? Nein, das waren ja Vögel im weitesten Sinne.
Und Vögel sind ja sehr schlau.
Raben sind schlau, Elzen sind sehr schlau. Ich meine, dumm im Sinne von haben keine Gesellschaft auf die Ketten bekommen.
Oder ist es so, dass sie tendenziell auch Hochhäuser hatten und zur Arbeit gegangen sind und Fernsehsendungen hatten und Fernseher hatten und Radar und so?
Ich glaube, erstens nein, ich erkläre dir warum,
weil wenn du zum Beispiel eine Fernbedienung designs für Dinosaurier,
wie gross machst du die?
Jeder Dinosaurier hat unterschiedlich grosse Hände.
Ich glaube, damit eine Gesellschaft entstehen kann,
muss die Bevölkerung zu einem gewissen Grad gleichförmig sein.
Weil wie gross machst du das Gebäude für den Dino-Tag?
Wie gross ist dein Stuhl?
Ist der gesamte Reichstag mit Stühlen besetzt, die gross genug wären für einen T-Rex? Gehst du default? Ja, es könnte ja sein, dass alle Abgeordneten T-Rex sind. Gut, also brauchen wir 200 T-Rex-Stühle. Und dann kommt da so ein Raptor-Angedacke, der sitzt dann auf so einem riesigen Stuhl. Ja, scheiße. Du musst ja solche Entscheidungen treffen. Das funktioniert halt nicht. Und deswegen glaube ich, das funktioniert nicht. Ich glaube, die müssen alle ungefähr gleich groß sein. Es gab eine Insel, wo es die gleichen Dinosaurier gab, aber in sehr klein, weil die Insel sehr klein war. Und ich finde das die lustigste Geschichte. Da gab es halt auch so einen Brontosaurus. Wir alle wissen, wie riesen Brontosaurier sind. Riesig. Du weißt ja ungefähr ein Verhause. Du hast mir deine Poster schon so aufgezeigt. Und dann gibt es eine kleine Insel und da fahren die gleichen Tiere, aber ganz klein drauf. Und irgendwann kam so ein Flugsaurier angeflogen und hat sich da hingesetzt und dachte mir, was ist denn hier los? Er hat einfach so... Und hat die gefressen. Wobei er dachte, ja, jetzt ist auch... Also, jetzt könnt ihr mich mal. Aber da wissen wir, dass Dinos genauso klug waren wie Menschen, weil der Mensch würde exakt dasselbe auch tun. Stell dir vor, du kommst irgendwie dann auf so eine Insel und dann sind die ganze Zivilisation klein und du sagst, die snack ich weg. Die schmeckt ein ein Mensch wie so Schokoboss. So eine 15 cm hohe Giraffe. Die wird so erstmal snack. Klar, so wie Popcorn. Ich würde die erstmal am Hals hochhalten. Guck mal, wie sie strampelt. Und dann die Türschlusspartei direkt, nein, leg die Garaffe weg. Dann würde ich zwei Giraffen nehmen und deren Hälse so zusammenknoten. Und die dann einfach mal laufen lassen. Und guck mal, was passiert. Aber das ist eh meine Idee, Tiere klein zu züchten. Ja. So große Tiere, so Elefanten auf so einer Tischgrösse, wie so Steiftiere und die dann bei sich zu Hause halten. Also so wie so ein Bonsai-Baum nur mit Tieren, dass du den einfach klein machst. Genau, einen ganz kleinen Elefanten und den kannst du am Tisch laufen lassen. Kann man eigentlich... Da muss man immer aufpassen, dass er nicht unterfällt. Da muss er in den Arm immer so. Ja, ja, ja. Kann man eigentlich in eine Schlange einen Knoten machen, der so stark ist, dass sie sich nicht mehr selber entknoten kann? Eigentlich nicht. Oder kann die sich immer dann rausschlängeln? Die können sich rausschlängeln. Ja? Deswegen das Wort rausschlängeln. Ja, stimmt. Guter Punkt. Da hast du mich. Daher kann das Wort rausschlängeln. Er hat versucht, können sich Schlangen rausschlängeln? Ja. Du, bei mir fängt ein neuer Lebensabschnitt an. Bei mir auch. Ja? Ich bin gespannt, was einer ist. Meiner ist, ich habe angefangen zu streamen. Nein. Einmal streamen. Oh, jetzt kommt es in die Werbeecke. Einmal streamen. Nee, nee, gar nicht. Das Podcast-Sufo-Werbung. Ich habe gestern angefangen zu streamen. Wirklich? Ja. Ich habe mal geguckt, ich habe ein bisschen auf Twitch rumgestreamt und es ist interessant, es könnte ein neues Hobby werden. Ich habe aber tatsächlich mich davor informiert,
so was sind die Gefahren, ich bin ein sehr vorsichtiger
Mensch geworden, was sind die Gefahren
des Streams und dann habe ich so gelesen, was es da
alles gibt, irgendwie so Swatting,
dass dann die Zuschauer zu dir nach Hause
die Polizei rufen und sagen, da ist jemand
und dann kommt und stürmt die
jetzt die neuen zur Tür.
Vielleicht wenn jetzt wirklich anfängst zu streamen.
Nee, das ist ja normal und dann habe ich mir so eine Compilation angeschaut von allen Skandalen. Da gab es dann einen Twitch-Streamer, der saß im Rollstuhl und irgendwann hat er noch nicht aufgepasst und ist einfach aufgestanden und gegangen. Und dann kam er zurück und hat ganz schnell den Stream beendet. Der Tap of Shame. Ein Wunder, ein Wunder. Nein. Wo ich mir denke, warum würde man beim Streamen so tun, als würde man im Rollstuhl sitzen? Weil als Rollstuhlfahrer hast du keinen Nachteil beim Streamen. Ja, aber Leute denken, oh, das ist ein Rollstuhl. Ja, aber gerade als Streamer noch nicht denkst du, ach cool, ist doch super, das ist ein Hobby oder ein Beruf, den er perfekt ausüben kann. Da hast du doch gerade kein Mitleid, da denkst du, der ist doch toll, genau das Richtige. Du hast auch kein Mitleid, wenn ein Rollstuhlfahrer irgendwie so Rollstuhlbasketball spielt oder so, dann denkst du, ah cool. Das ist wie diese Instagramerin, die irgendwann mal behauptet hat, sie hätte Krebs. Und dann kam raus, dass sie es nicht hat. Und dann hat sie behauptet, sie hat sich immer weiter in dieses Lügengebäude verzogen. Irgendwann gemeint, nee, ist das jetzt geheilt? Weil irgendwer hat das nämlich dann geleakt, dann hat sie gesagt, nee, der ist jetzt geheilt. Und dann hat sie irgendwann wieder behauptet, dass sie Krebs hat. Das ist wirklich wahr. Manchmal hat man Pech. Die Geschichte muss man doch mal rausholen. Aber das ist wirklich, dann wahrscheinlich behauptet der auch behauptet, nee, das ist nur, jetzt ist es wieder im Rollstuhl. Zu sehr reingesteigert einfach. Das Klavier ist jetzt auf mich draufgefallen. Ah, schlimm. Einfach so. Schlimm. Aber ich habe tatsächlich panische Angst, dass ich irgendwann mal die Kamera anlasse und dann irgendwie keine Ahnung mir einen runterhole oder so. Und dann keine Ahnung, dann ist das dann für immer im Internet und du kriegst nicht mehr weg,
irgendwie bist du in diesen Twitch-Compilations, klar kriegst du Follower, logisch, aber es ist auch schwierig.
Ich habe da echt großen Respekt davor.
Oder du verlierst dann Follower.
Ja, es kann auch sein.
Aber eine Frage, was streamst du genau?
Hauptsächlich Warcraft 3.
Warcraft 3?
Spiele ich dann so ein bisschen.
Es ist ein Strategiespiel, ja. Nee, es ist ein Strategiespiel. Warum auch Warcraft? Es ist die gleiche Welt, aber unterschiedliche Spiele. Na gut. World of Warcraft ist ein Rollenspiel und Warcraft 3 ist ein Strategiespiel. Ja, ja, ja, nee gut, nee, freue ich mich. Nee, okay, und ja, ich habe das gestern gemacht, es ist wahnsinnig zeitverschlingen. Raubend.
Ich habe angefangen, 14 Uhr, gucke irgendwann auf die Uhr, oh, 21 Uhr, krass, irgendwie geht es wahnsinnig schnell weg, aber es macht Spaß. Und ich habe heute mit einem sehr erfolgreichen Streamer gesprochen und vielleicht wird das, der hat mir ein paar Tipps gegeben, vielleicht wird das noch was. Cool. Grosse Streamerkarriere und dann kommen auch lauter Skandale, dass dann irgendwie die Katze, wo ich gesagt habe, die ist tot, kommt dann im Hintergrund nochmal reingelaufen oder so. Nee, aber da habe ich ein bisschen Angst davor. Als dein Podcast-Kollege will ich jetzt nicht mehr reingezogen werden in so ein Lügengebäude, was er dann da aufbaut. Aber kann man das nicht absichtlich machen, irgendwie so eine Geschichte, dass man immer sagt, mein Mitbewohner ist verloren gegangen oder so? Oh, eine gute Idee, ein fiktionales Aufbau in einer Streaming-Gestalt. Müssen wir jetzt einen guten Schauspieler finden, von der Schauspielschule, und dann so eine Streaming-Geschichte aufbauen. Das gab es aber auch schon mal. Irgendjemand hat einen YouTube-Kanal gemacht? Oder war das eine Serie? Und die hat dann irgendwie gesagt, ihre Freundin ist verschwunden. Und dann hat sie immer gesagt, ist hier halt irgendwie Tränen ausgebrochen und und gesagt, ja, die wurde das letzte Mal da gesehen. Und dann sind sie im Zimmer so
Hinweise verstreut. Und dann haben ganz viele
Leute, haben dann die Freundin gesucht
und dann haben die irgendwie eine Leiche im Wald
gefunden und dann haben die die Leiche gefolgt und die hatte dann
irgendwie so ein T-Shirt an Snickers und das war
dann irgendwie so ein Werbedeal, so ein
Werbeding.
Ne, ist jetzt nicht richtig, aber
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung war,
glaube ich. Die haben sich ein bisschen
übers Ziel hinausgeschossen.
Und Snickers auch irgendwann so
sorry.
Also da müssen wir jetzt echt mal
sagen. Also unsere Riegel sind immer noch geil, aber
ja, ja, richtig geil, Fünferpark,
eins umsonst, aber
sorry,
grosse Sorry, da haben wir uns verrannt. Da haben wir uns verrannt. Es gibt auch so ganz viele Geschichten von YouTubern, die hatten irgendwie so einen Leberfleck am Hals oder so, und dann hat irgendjemand mal geschrieben, ja, ich bin Hautarzt, dein Leberfleck wird größer, geh mal zum Arzt. Und dann ist sie zum Arzt gegangen, ja, irgendwie konnte noch raus operiert werden und irgendwie sowas Leben gerettet. Nee, sie hat jetzt glaube ich wieder Krebs. Ist doch tot.
Nee, jetzt wieder Krebs, glaube ich.
Simone Gierth hat sie, glaube ich, die ist ganz toll.
Hat immer noch einen tollen Channel,
aber ich glaube, der Krebs ist zurück. Ist nicht so cool.
Nee, ist nicht cool, aber
auf jeden Fall auch ein Ersatz
für einen Arzt. Ja, das ist für einen Arzt.
Du musst eben zum Arzt gehen, du streamst einfach und sagst,
ach, das ist ja in Theorie, weil du so hypochondrisch
veranlagt bist, dass du zwischendurch einfach mal Fragen stellen kannst. Also erstmal, in sieben Stunden Warcraft 3 sind Fragen wie, naja, wie soll ich mein Geld an? Das ist ja eigentlich, wie das dieser Lieberfelschicht, der gesund ausnebt. Ich hab hier so ein Ziehen im Hals da und dann hält man das so genau in die Kamera, genau hier. Ja. Und dann versteckt ihr damit genau die richtige Möglichkeit. Aber versteckt in sieben Stunden Warcraft 3 Fun. Stunden Warcraft 3 Fun. Nee, finde ich gut. Meine neue Phase ist tatsächlich das Kochen. Und das ist wirklich so eine Phase, wo ich sage, das ist wirklich mal, weil ich habe schon Phasen durchgemacht, in denen ich gesteckt habe, wo ich gedacht habe, das ist Bullshit. Ich weiß, ich war bei vielen dabei. Ich gucke immer noch gerne in Formel 1, aber diese Hardcore-Phase, wo ich dann das Wissen reingeballert habe die ganze Zeit, hat mich nirgendwo hingeführt. Meistens habe ich vergessen, ich wusste viel über Formel-1-Motoren und so. Ich bin halt jemand, der nerdet sich dann gerne in so Inselwissen rein. Und was ich dann in Kurzzeit gedessen gespeichert habe, wie so ein Skript auswendig lernen für ein Theaterstück oder so was, so für eine kurze Zeit hab ich das dann total drin. Und dann vergess sich alles wieder, die meisten Sachen. Wohingegen aber jetzt die Kochphase ist wirklich gut, glaub ich. Weil da speichere ich mir Dinge ab, die ich dann einfach gut anwenden kann. Und was kochst du so? Ich hab viel gekocht, ich hab Knochenmark tatsächlich gekocht. Also viele Sachen. Einfach mal besondere Sachen, die nicht jeder kocht. Ich habe zum Muttertag bei der Mutter ein Dreier-Gänge-Menü gekocht. Da war ich sehr stolz drauf. Mit überbackenem Spargel, Knochenmark, selbstgemachten Röstzwiebeln. Knochenmark? Wie? Ich habe überlegt, was für ein Advanced-Fleischgericht ich machen kann. Und dann wollte ich erst ein Lebergericht machen, aber dann gab es bei dem örtlichen Supermarkt an der Frischotheke keinen Leber. Deswegen hatten die aber so Knochenmark-Stücke. Das kennen niemanden. Sorry, ganz kurz. Knochenmark ist das Zeug im Knochen. Mark-Knochen, ja. Das sind wie so abgeschnittene Knochen und da drin hast du so ein ganz feines Knochenmark. Es ist einfach wie, es ist halt so sehr fetthaltig, aber wahnsinnig lecker. Und was ist das für eine Konsistenz? Ja, so wie Leberwurst. Um es nicht zu sagen, schleimig. Ja? So helles, weisses, fetthaltiges, sieht nicht so geil aus, aber es ist halt wahnsinnig lecker. Es ist ein Delikatesse so ein bisschen. Aber wie isst man das dann? Dann mit Pommes einfach, oder was? Nö, ich habe es mit selbstgemachten Röstschiebeln serviert, als Vorspeise. Schön. Als Vorspeise? Ja, habe ich als Vorspeise. Und dann so löffelt man das dann weg? Löffelt man aus, snackt man weg, snackt man da raus aus dem Knochen. Aus dem Knochen? Ja. Aber ist es denn wie so ein langer Strohhalm, oder ist das... Chef Tietze will jetzt nicht alle seine Gerichte verraten.
Ja, nee, nee, okay, ich will es da gar nicht in dein geheimes Kochbuch reinsteuern. Aber wow, nicht schlecht. Ja, das war advanced. Man findet aber auch, muss man sagen, viele Gerichte einfach im Internet. Ich finde aber auch Kochen noch nicht so ganz durchblickt, weil ich denke, wenn man, kommt es sich nur auf das Rezept an und wenn das Rezept gut ist, dann klappt das schon. Also hier bleibt klar, aber man so ein bisschen Wissen über wann kochen Dinge, wann garen Dinge, wann sind Dinge zu heiß, Flüssigkeiten und so. Also so ein gewisses Aggregatszustand Wissen. Ich habe dann noch ein Rezept gekocht und dann stand irgendwie als letzter Punkt, da sah ich irgendwie 200 Gramm Mehl, bla bla bla, und letzter Schritt war Abschmeckencken. Dann denke ich mir, ja, Leute, dafür habe ich doch kein Rezept.
Die Idee des Rezept war es, nicht abschmecken zu müssen.
Genau, das ist ja genau das, was ich nicht kann.
Ich schmecke nichts. Ich kann nicht sagen, vor allem dann zu schmecken und zu sagen,
weil du musst ja schon den Zielgeschmack irgendwo haben, wenn du sagst, ein bisschen mehr Salz.
Ich habe überhaupt kein Konzept. Also wie speichert das Gehirn das Geschmack? Wie wäre es mit, schmeckt es dir ja oder nein? Ja, wenn ich sage nein. Dann mach es aber anders. Und dann noch ein bisschen Kümmel. Probier mal rum. Ja, wie? Das ist doch Chaos. Ja, genau, aber ich glaube, das ist wie bei allen Berufen, einfach mal rumprobieren. Ja, aneignen. Ja, aber du weißt ja nicht, wie gut es schmecken kann. Also ich meine, klar. Dann gehe ich gut essen. Und das speichere ich dann ab und dann sage ich so. Ich glaube, dass du Geschmäcker und Gerüche kannst dir, glaube ich, besser merken als Worte. Und dann fummelst du so lange mit Salz und Pfeffer rum, bis du angekommen bist. Bis du angekommen bist, ja. Der große Tristetrink ist übrigens Salz, Pfeffer und Butter. Einfach nur Butter. Ja, auch Butter, super. Ohne Scheiss, der Grund, warum Dinge im Restaurant besser schmecken, ist die Menge an Butter. Ohne Scheiss, es ist einfach das. Das ist alles. Mehr Fett. Ja, mehr Geschmacksträger. Ja. Ich war ja auch fasziniert. Ich glaube, ich habe weitreichendere Phasen als du. Du hast so alle sechs Monate eine neue Phase. Ja. Bei mir ist es immer so, ich hätte gerne eine neue Phase, überlege, ob ich eine Phase anfangen soll und fange sie dann nicht an. Beantragst in deinem Kopf eine neue Phase? Richtig. Abgelehnt. Ich glaube, ich habe vier Monate gebraucht, um zum Streamen hinzukommen. Und ich hatte ja auch... Du bist lange vor dich hingemurmelt, dass du das machen möchtest. Das stimmt schon. Vielleicht, ja, keine Ahnung. Und dann, ich überlege ja manchmal, ob ich vielleicht mit Alkohol anfangen soll. Ich habe auch ein paar Geschichten von dir gehört, aber ob ich so weinkenner-mässig anfangen soll. Weil das wäre, da würde ich mich sehen. Ich weiß aber selber, dass es völlig unrealistisch ist. Würde ich auch sehen. Und ich war jetzt in München. Ich bin klar an Alkoholismus abgedriftet. Ja, sozial. Ich weiß nicht, in welchem Stand ihr noch seid. Ich habe wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Folge 38 Mal erzählt, dass ich einen Alkohol trinke. Ich habe dich gesehen mit einem Corona in der Hand. Wann? Und dann ist dir das so ein bisschen ausgekommen, weil du schon ein bisschen angeheitert warst. Und dann hast du so Corona über deinen Ärmel. Du hattest so einen Pulli an und du hast dir dein Corona so ein bisschen über den Ärmel geschüttet. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, Stefan, stürzt ab, hast du sozusagen dein Ärmel ausgesaugt? Wo genau? Wo hast du Corona aus dem Ärmel rausgesaugt? Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, einerseits sich selber mit Alkohol zu beschmutzen, okay, aber dann noch zu sagen, das gebe ich nicht her. Da war es schon spät, es war gute 18 Uhr schon, da war ich schon ein bisschen neben der Spur. Aber ich war in München und da war ich beim Manufaktaktum und da gibt's und das ist ein Produkt, das hat mich tagelang fasziniert, weil man kennt ja so, wenn man über Weine redet, dann sagt man immer so, ah, nussige Note oder vanilliges Aroma oder solche Vokabeln. Du hast dann so eine Art Mineralisch. Genau, so hast du Vokabeln, mit denen man einen Geschmack beschreiben kann. Und viele machen sich darüber lustig, aber es ist ja schon wichtig, dass wenn man einen Wein, man muss ja einen Wein irgendwie beschreiben können mit Worten. Und dann gibt es halt einfach so diese. Die Musik beschreiben, ist schwierig. Ja genau, ist schwierig, aber es gibt ein Vokabular. Und was ich da gefunden habe, war eine Aromenkiste. Und es war eine Kiste, so eine Art Vitrine mit irgendwie, glaube ich, 30 Fläschchen. Und du hattest 30 so Aromen in Reinform. Und da stand drüber, das ist für Weinkenner. Und jeder Weinkenner hat die sozusagen drin als Vokabular. Und dann kannst du, wenn du einen Wein trinkst, kannst du sagen, ah, das schmeckt so ähnlich wie Kirsche mit einem Hauch Vanille. Und dadurch hast du sozusagen eine genormte Sprache für Weine, weil jeder Weinkenner kennt diese 30 Standardaromen.
Kennt Normalkirchen.
Genau, genau, die Normalkirche.
Die Fallkirche.
Ja, und dann Normalholz und da gab es dann auch irgendwie sowas wie Leder oder sowas, also irgendwie jetzt nicht nahrungsspezifische. Aber das ist ja genial, weil da kannst du wirklich, wie du jetzt irgendwie, dann sag ich mal, bewusster Musik wahrnimmst, kannst du so die Aromen in Reinform mal schmecken, um dann einfach so eine Palette aufzubauen, wie also eine Farbpalette. Das würde ich gerne mal für Musik machen. Das wäre schon spannend. Ich würde mit euch Hörern gerne einmal so einen Musikexkurs machen. Ja? Dann einmal so, jetzt reden wir über klassische Musik, am besten jetzt so. Und das ist ein Staccato, das ist ein erdiger Sound, das ist ein luftiger Sound, das ist ein voller Klang. Ja, aber das kannst du nicht beschreiben, das ist Magie, das fühlt jeder anders. Aber wie ein Aromen doch auch. Es muss doch Wörter geben. Natürlich gibt es da ja auch für Kirschig gibt es ja auch ein Spektrum. Ja gut, aber da hast du zumindest die objektive Kirsche in der Welt. Wenn du sagst, ein blubbernder Rhythmus, klar ist blubbernd schon irgendeine Art von Objektivität, aber es ist, ob das jetzt blubbert oder nicht. Bisschen despektierlich. Hä, wieso blubbernd? Ja, dass ich meine Kunst als blubbernd bezeichne. Was wäre denn für dich blubbernd? Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub, so ein blubbernder Basszaun. So ein bisschen krötig, so blub,ubbern so von etwas... Unrhythmisch. Für mich ist Blubbern etwas, was von unten nach oben kommt. Ich stelle mir vor, so Luftblasen, die so... Schau mal, jetzt hat ein bisschen... Das ist ein Glissando. Das Wort... So. Nee, Glissando ist ja ein Ton. Blubbern wäre so... Nee, Glissando ist nicht ein Ton, aber ist ja auch egal. Schau mal, wir können uns nicht mal über die Grundbegriffe einigen. Nee, weil du falsch liegst. Okay, guter Punkt. Aber zum Beispiel hat jetzt das Wort Blubbern bei uns völlig unterschiedliche Assoziationen ausgeliefert. Blubbern ist für mich auch vor allem unrhythmisch, weil Blubberblasen niemals rhythmisch platzen. Das ist immer ein Blubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbubbub folgende Frage gestellt. Was ist überhaupt Rhythmus? Man denkt schon, das Projekt, was er am Ende abgibt, ist scheiße. Dann habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, muss man Geschmack immer schmecken oder kann man Geschmack auch manchmal fühlen? Und man denkt, ja, in diesem Restaurant will ich nicht essen. Dann habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, muss man immer satt werden? Ja, gute Nacht, ciao. Aber ich glaube, was total hilft, ist, wenn man die Unterschiede möglichst klein macht. Beispiel, es gibt in Chefstable, gibt es diesen einen, ich glaube, Schweden oder skandinavischen Koch und der hat also so ganz sag ich mal, standard hausmännische Sachen und der hat dann zum Beispiel serviert ein Stück Brot mit drei verschiedenen Buttern, das ist der Amerikaner gewesen, von, ja okay, aber war irgendwo jetzt kein Name, von drei verschiedenen Kühen, drei Butter aus der Milch von drei Kühen. Und er hat auch jemandem erklären lassen, dem Servicepersonal, woher das kommt, welche Kuh das war und so. Aber das ist doch genial. Es ist doch viel besser, du lernst doch viel mehr über Butter, wenn du zwei verschiedene Butter isst, die fast identisch sind. Und dann zu gucken, was ist der Unterschied? Also, ich weiß nicht, ob das auch wieder so... Er hat auch ein Gericht, The Three Stages of Chicken, wo ein Ei, Hühnerfleisch und dann noch was anderes. Ich weiß nicht, was die dritte Stage war. Federn. Ich weiß nicht, was die dritte Stage war. Ich glaube, bei Huhn und Ei gibt es relativ offensichtlich zwei Phasen, nicht drei. Ei, hmm. Totes Küken, totes Huhn. Weiß ich nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt. Stimmt schon wahrscheinlich. The two stages of, ich weiß nicht mehr. Oder halt vielleicht dann wieder Ei. Ei, Huhn, Ei. Dann hast du so ein Unendlichkeitsgegn. Da kommt auch jemand, der sagt, das sind unterschiedliche Hühner, aber dann sagt sie, ja. Das ist ein unterschiedliches Restaurant und du sagst, ich will eigentlich nur essen und du sagst so, sie haben jetzt hier einen Teller Pasta, jede einzelne Nudel ist von einem anderen Getreidefeld in Südostitalien. Schauen Sie, okay, alles klar, danke, alles klar, noch mehr Ketchup, bitte. Aber ja, und es gibt auch ein Restaurant bei Chefstable von einem Typen, dem irgendwann mal einumpel einen Vapor gezeigt hat, wo man auch Kräuter drin verrauchen kann. Und der dann, natürlich weil er so ein abgefahrener Molekularchef ist, hat er dann belegt, er verbraucht, er verdampft Aromen und macht die in so eine Luft, so ein Ballonartiges Ding rein und macht dann einen Kissenüberzug drüber. Da hast du so ein Kissen und dann sticht ein Kellner mit einem Messer in das Kissen und dann kommt er.
Ein bisschen zu gewalttätig. Ja, dann kommt das Aroma raus. Und dann sollst du was essen und musst dann ins Kissen stechen und dann kommen verschiedene Aromen aus dem Kissen heraus. Aber ist das nicht Cheaten? Ich meine, ist nicht Schmecken, eh nur über Nase. Und dann während du was isst, dann noch was in die Nase stecken. Das ist ganz geil, aber auf jeden Fall ein krasser Koch. Aber weißt du, was, glaube ich, meine Horrorvorstellung wäre, wenn man feststellen würde, dass Rinder unterschiedlich schmecken, wenn sie unterschiedliche Sachen vapen, und man dann die Rinder vapen lässt? Weil es gibt ja klar, die Rinder unterschiedliches Heu ist unterschiedliche Qualität, aber wenn du sagst, ja, ich lasse meine Kuh nur so ... Oh, wenn man coole Kühe auf dem Feld vapen sieht und dann steckt immer so eine Rauchfahrt
auf und sagt, oh, die herrliche wirben.
Und dann so im Geschäftsabelschiff
ja, ich habe jetzt festgestellt, dass wenn man Kühe immer
Vanille vapen lässt, dass dann das Fleisch so ein bisschen
nach Vanille schmeckt und die Kühe nur so, oh Gott.
Ja, aber auch der Kumpel.
Wir werden schon geschlachtet. Muss das sein?
Naja, aber vielleicht eine Kuh, die sagt, nur vapen.
Ich würde es mal probieren.
Ich würde es machen. Mu, mu, mu, mu. Aber auch der Kumpel, der den Vapor zeigt, und danach ist es ein Gericht in seinem crazy Restaurant, wo man auch sagt, sei vorsichtig, zeig dem nicht Mario Kart, wir haben alle keinen Bock, wir wollen einfach essen. Zeig dem nicht Kaugummizigaretten. Wir sollen uns den Hamburger machen. Ich fände es aber auch gut, wenn dann irgendwie so, dann kommt dieser Freund und zeigt ihm das Vapen, und ab dann folgt die Doku Vaper-Freund und wir gehen komplett weg von dem Restaurant und der hängt so zu Hause und vapet so und man denkt sich, ich will den Koch sehen. Ein langweiliges Leben dafür. Der Abspann. Abspann. Und mit dieser krassen, klassischen Musik von Chefstable. Ja, ist es toll. Ja, und dann habe ich halt, wie ist mein Tagesablauf, ja, ich komme morgen zur Arbeit, dann habe ich ja, ich habe mir bei Amazon ein paar von diesen Geschmäckern bestellt,
ich habe mal Lavendel probiert und...
Wollen wir ein Restaurant machen?
Lass uns ein Restaurant machen.
Oh, es ist übrigens super spannend, wir wollen ja dann auch Sterne bekommen, Michelin-Sterne.
Ja, oder Monde.
Und viel cooler, es ist der Tag, also Michelin-Sterne? Ja, oder Monde. Und viel cooler, Michelin-Sterne bekommt man so,
dass in einem
Jahr unangekündigt
erst einer und dann ein zweiter
Michelin-Tester kommen in dein Restaurant.
Sind die auch so weiss und
ganz dick? Ganz weiss, die erkennst
du nicht, außer dass sie unglaublich dick und
weiss sind und dick Michelin
draufsteht. Aber es ist wirklich von dem
Reifenhersteller. Ja, Michelin. Weil früher war das in Trucker-Magazinen drin. Ein Stern, Restaurants wurden so bewertet. Ein Stern ist ein Stopp wert, zwei ist ein Umweg wert, drei ist eine Reise wert. Herrlich. Jetzt will ich Trucker werden. Ich will Koch werden. Ja, okay. Aber okay, für Sie ist das dabei. Jetzt will ich Trucker werden. Das ist nicht die Morale der Geschichte. Und dann kommen die unangekündigt und teilweise auch mit Familien und so, dass du keine Chance hast, die zu erkennen. Das war so eine Fake-Familie von Schauspielern. Alles Schauspieler. Der Freund eines Arbeitskollegen hat keinen Stern bekommen, weil der erste kam, er hat ihm auch einen Stern gegeben. Zweite hat dann keinen Tisch mehr bekommen in dem Jahr, einfach, durch Zufall. Ja, aber das läuft in die Bewertung des Restaurants mit ein, ob man einen Tisch kriegt. Nee, der konnte einfach nicht, der konnte nicht bewerten. Ach so. Weil die kommen ganz normal, die melden sich an, kommen dann hin und Restaurants müssen aber sehr viel aufwenden und sehr viel in Vorleistung treten, wenn die einen Stern bekommen, weil du musst halt schon ein weirdes Konzept an den Tag legen und dass du, ein Restaurant kann nicht ewig auf einen Stern warten, weil du musst sehr viel in Vorleistung treten und sehr viel aufwenden, um einen Stern zu bekommen und dann hilft ein Stern natürlich, um danach die Kundschaft ranzutreiben, aber wenn der Stern nicht kommt, dann musst du irgendwann auch ein Restaurant sagen, okay, dann verbrebreiten wir jetzt wieder das Konzept und machen einfach eine breite Karte.
Aber muss dann diese Fake-Tester-Familie auch so Fake-Gespräche führen, während sie essen?
Ja, exakt.
Also der eine hat dann...
Wir geben ein Skript.
Und dann so, und wie war dein Tag, Schatz?
Schön.
Gut, sehr, sehr gut.
Und na Kinder, wie war es in der Schule?
Sehr gut, Frau Meier und die Kinder sind sehr schlechte Schauspieler, obviously.
Oder der Koch so, verdammt nochmal, Frau Meier hat dir eine Zwei gegeben? Moment mal, letzte Woche hat sie gesagt, sie ist bei Frau Rüppel. Du bist von Michelin! Und alle so, oh no, no, no Michelin. Oh den Feuerlöscher! Drei Sterne. Es sind aber wirklich, glaube ich, echte Familien. Ich habe, es gibt eine sehr gute Doku über ein Sushi-Restaurant, Yuri Dreams of Sushi, Yuri oder Jogi. Diesen Typen, der da alleine sitzt. Ich glaube, Yuri. Und da geht es in der Doku so ein bisschen um ihn und seinen Sohn. Weil der Sohn soll das Restaurant übernehmen so ein bisschen und er ist halt so der krasse Sushi-Meister, der halt Sushi perfektioniert. und dann siehst du ganz genau, dass dann irgendwie, der hat ganz viele Konzepte und super krass und am Ende geht es halt darum, ob er diese Drei-Sterne-Wertung kriegt oder irgendwie so, das Beste, was man kriegen kann und am Ende heißt es dann so, ja, der hat drei Sterne bekommen am Ende und an allen Tagen, an denen die Tester da waren, hat sein Sohn Sushi gemacht. Oh, what? Ja. Geil. Das ist schon echt ein geiles Ende für eine Doku, ja. Es gibt so geile Doku-Enden. Ich will es nicht zu viel verraten. Du hast es ein bisschen gespoilt jetzt. Naja, egal. Der Film ist zehn Jahre alt. Um Dokus ist es ja auch egal. Es gibt diese tolle Doku über die Flat-Earth-er, auch bei Netflix. Ja. Und ich muss sagen, ich habe echt die liebgewonnen im Laufe der Doku, weil die sagen, und wir beweisen euch auch, dass die Erde flach ist. Und ich denk mir so, ja geil, glaubt da gern dran, wenn euer Drang nicht ist, Leute zu beeinflussen ohne Fakten, sondern herauszufinden und zu falsifizieren, eure Theorie mega. Und es endet halt damit, wie sie auf ihren Testergebnissen starren und sagen, na scheiße, und dann Abspann kommt und man denkt, geil, das ist die beste Fakie-Doku. Schau mal die Flat-Earth-Doku bei Netflix, die jetzt gar keinen Spaß mehr macht, würde ich so wissen. Nee, auf jeden Fall. Nee, schon mal. Aber wenn es so eine Doku ist, dann ist es gut, weil ich dachte, es ist so und wir machen uns über, also ich dachte, es ist eine Flat-Earth-Doku von Flat-Ethern, und man schaut sich die an, um sich über die lustig zu machen. Nee, nee. Ah, okay. Weil da war ich mir nicht sicher, ob ich mir die anschauen kann, weil ich denke, wenn ich den jetzt ... Es ist von Leuten von normalos, über Flat-Earther, um sich über die lustig zu machen, die aber auf der Reise erkennen, dass es mehr dahinter steckt, als sich über die lustig zu machen. Es sind ja auch Leute, die dann oft sich einen Sinn suchen, also in ihrem Leben was Besonderes zu sein. Es sind ja meistens Leute, die gar nichts Besonderes sind und diesen Drang haben, den ja jeder Mensch hat, irgendwie was aus sich zu machen. Und in dem Moment, wo du natürlich kannst, das total einfach machen, wenn du sagst, okay, aber ich gehöre jetzt zu den wenigen Leuten, die das wissen, dass die Erde flach ist. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und dann glaube ich, kann man sich auch so zu einem gewissen Grad einreden. Du bist was Besonderes. Du bist wieder der Einzige, der es weiss. Ich hab's durchschaut. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen die Theorie, dass viele Verschwörungstheorien nur so erfolgreich sind, weil es so viel Spaß macht, sich über die lustig zu machen. Weil viele auch außerhalb der Verschwörungstheorie-Bubble Aufmerksamkeit zur Zeit und Artikel schreiben und Videos machen und so. Und es ist natürlich wichtig, über die aufzuklären, aber ich glaube, würde man die einfach ignorieren, würden die nie so große Tragweite bekommen, weil in deren Verschwörungstheorie Mindset ist natürlich auch immer drin, ja, die Medien wollen uns klein halten, die Medien machen uns schlecht, das sind alles bezahlte Trolle, wir müssen enger zusammenrücken, wir müssen mehr dagegen kämpfen. Und jeder, der medienskeptisch ohnehin schon ist, was ja viele Menschen sind, sieht dann diese, guckt euch mal die Trottel an und denkt sich, naja, die haben dann auch Bock auf diese Antimedienschiene.
Und ich glaube, es wäre fast besser, die einfach zu ignorieren, was schwer ist, weil sie sind sehr dumm und es macht Spaß und sehr lustig. Und viele denken, haha, wenn wir uns so lange genug mit die lustig machen, dann schwächen wir die, aber ich glaube, man stärkt sie eher, weil dadurch natürlich die Aufmerksamkeit auf die ist. Und viele dann auch so sagen, ah, okay, vielleicht ist da was dran, habe ich mal gehört, aber ich weiß es nicht. Es ist schwierig. Nicht ganz der Streisand-Effekt, aber ungefähr. Ja, es ist schwierig. Ja, genau, du generierst halt einfach Aufmerksamkeit. Ja, ich glaube, es sind aber auch, es sind schon die richtigen Theorien bekannt, die nämlich die, über die es Spaß macht, sich lustig zu machen. War nicht Galilei damals auch ein Verschwörungstheoretiker in den Augen der Gesellschaft? Sind Verschwörungen klar? Ja, aber der hatte ja Beweise. Also der hat das ja wissenschaftlich untersucht. Der hat ja mit seinem Stethoskop in den Himmel geguckt. Ja, ich sag nur, im gesellschaftlichen... Ja gut, aber so ist jeder Wissenschaftler ein Verschwörungstheoretiker, bevor seine Theorie anerkannt ist. Ja. Das kannst du ja auch nicht sagen. Gut, so denken viele Verschwörungstheoretiker. Nee, genau, jetzt ist mir die Frage, wie man das definiert. Die Leute, die wir jetzt als Verschwörungstheoretiker bezeichnen, verfechtern natürlich Theorien, wo es Beweise dagegen gibt. Ja, aber die Leute, die Galileo widersprochen haben, haben ja nicht widersprochen aufgrund von wissenschaftlichen Fakten, sondern weil es in der Bibel steht. Ja, genau. Und das ist eine andere Art von Argumentation, als wenn man jetzt heute sagt, ah, hier sind wissenschaftliche Fakten, warum die Erde keine Scheibe ist. Aber es stimmt schon, ist es schon gut, dass man... Vor dem Punkt, wo er Fakten hatte. Ja, es ist schon gut, dass man auch das Bewusstsein schafft, dass jemand, der an Chemtrail glaubt, Depp ist, weil du dann einfach sagst, wenn jemand am Esstisch anfängt, über Chemtrail zu reden, weißt du genau, okay, kannst ihn sofort einordnen und kannst dann auch allen sofort sagen, passt auf. Und es sind auch oft Leute aus dem rechten Spektrum. Das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr seltsame Verkettung, finde ich immer. Ich stelle mir vor allem immer vor, wie das in diesen Verschwörungstheoretiker-Kreisen ist, weil die haben ja teilweise auch komplett widersprüchliche Theorien, gerade bei 9-11. Die sind alle klar, dass 9-11 ein Inside-Job war, aber die Hälfte sagt, das war eine Rakete, die andere Hälfte sagt, das war eine Sprengung. Das ist ein großes Problem. Und wie unterhalten die sich denn miteinander? Das ist auch ein Thema bei dieser Netflix-Doku, weil es gibt halt die, die trennen sich da nochmal auf. Es gibt nämlich die, die glauben, wir leben in einer Kuppel, und der Himmel ist ein Bildschirm, und es gibt die, die glauben ... Bildschirm? Der Himmel ist ein Bildschirm, und es gibt Leute, die glauben, die Sonne dreht sich so über diese Scheibe. Alle haben aber so sehr holozentristische Weltbilder, also dass Universum irgendwie ein Fake ist und wir aber in einem Versuchsglas sind oder die Sonne um sich um die Erde dreht und so weiter. Aber das ist schon auch interessant und die raufen sich halt zusammen für so eine Tagung, aber man merkt so, die Hälfte des Publikums zuckt so mit den Augen, wenn jemand sagt, und deswegen müssen wir raus dieser Kuppel, weil die sagen, ja, aber daran glauben wir nicht. Wir sind hier, aber wir werden... Soweit nicht. Dankeschön. Soweit nicht. Aber das ist schon interessant. Oder zwei Leute, die sagen, die Erde ist schon flach, oder? Die Erde ist flach, oder? Und ich meine, dass die Medien das nicht sagen, ist ja klar, die sind ja alle bezahlt. Und ich meine, Hitler lebt auf dem Mond, oder? Ist das auch klar? Nee, was? Ja, Hitler lebt auf dem Mond natürlich. Wie? Ja, Hitler lebt auf dem Mond, klar. Aber die Retheloiden haben ihn entführt und von der Erde auf dem Mond, als er nach Argentinien geflohen ist. Ja, klar. Argentinien? Ich glaube nicht an. Wie? Ich glaube nicht an Argentinien. Wie? Ja, natürlich Argentinien, das Land, in das Hitler geflohen ist. Nein, es gibt, Hitler ist erstens nicht geflohen und zweitens glaube ich an das Land Argentinien nicht. Wir sind die Argentinienlosen. Wir glauben, dass Südamerika nicht aus Argentinien ist. Aber er ist schon flach. Ja, er ist schon flach. Argentinien ist flach. Argentinien existiert nicht. Argentinien ist eine Idee der Briten. Briten existieren nicht. Was? Briten existieren nicht. Du hast ein Wort für die Briten. Scheiße, das recht.
Aber ich glaube,
das mit Hitler schon.
Sorry, ich glaube es halt einfach.
Wie viele Beweise hast du?
Fotos, die so ein bisschen verwackelt sind und unscharf.
Alle von einer Quelle?
Ja.
Nicken anerkennt.
Anerkenntnis nicken, yes.
Verwackelte Fotos aus einer Kelle.
Ich liebe es, das ist mein Elixier.
Ach ja.
Ach, herrlich.
Das war eine schöne weitere Folge des DPU, das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projektes.
Sind wir nächste Woche? Nein.
Nein, du bist ganz falsch.
Ich bin völlig falsch. Du bist im Kalender verrutscht. Wir sind am 5.6. in Leipzig. Nein, du bist ganz falsch. Ich bin völlig falsch.
Wir sind am 5.6. in Leipzig.
Ja, wir freuen uns sehr auf euch, wie ihr kommt.
Wir freuen uns sehr auf euch, genau.
Tickets gibt es, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Nee. Vielen Dank.
Aber Dankeschön.
Also vielen Dank an Debbie für das fantastische Intro.
Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank an die Sonne, dafür, dass ihr uns immer Wärme schenkt,
auf unserem runden Planeten.
Vielen Dank an die Erde, dass wir auf ihr laufen dürfen. Geht gerne wählen. Ja, Mond, du könntest dich ein bisschen mehr anstrengen. Feedback für nächste Woche. Wenig Licht. Es kam mal mehr Licht vom Mond. Nur mal so als These rausgehauen. Einfach ein paar Lux oben drauf. Verfalsifiziert mir immer das. Ich glaube einfach mal dran. Vom Mond kam mal mehr Reflexionslicht. Der Mond nimmt ab. Der Mond hat keinen Bock mehr.
Von dem Mond kommt ein bisschen weniger zurück.
Wir geben wenig geben.
Bis nächste Woche, wir heben ab.
Macht's gut, ciao.